applaudissements pour rien sinon y'a
seydoux gatineau gas étudiants non ça va
tout va bien cirilli as tu as profité
que les écoles soient fermés pour
recevoir une collégienne ou hd j'ai
explosé j'étais le phénomène du moment
être humain j'ai jamais rencontrées par
si je rentre sans rue mais j'ai pas fait
de scène g3 choqué de 4 showcase depuis
que bah je suis connue mais ça m'énerve
parce que j'aimerais a perdu ce n est
tout désigné en décembre et j'espère
qu'il va pas être annulée parce que des
lames à tournon l'annuler ça m'énerve
voilà frère elle a 16 ans elle va faire
un zénith moi j'ai deux filles de 13 et
14 ans bougez vous le cul les filles de
9 à zenit à 16 ans killian m.bah paix
champion du monde à 19 ans et toiles y
avait la tarnaise belattar 13 14 ans
vous servez à rien cette pause a well
done vient de rééditer son album mais sa
pochette m'a interloqué et ray est belle
visiblement va se présenter en 2022
moi je dis pourquoi pas c'est tellement
le désert à couches d'ailleurs regardez
ce sondage de gauche allait en tête
devant achats écolo sa série l'ia tu as
reçu mon chouchou notre fils à nous deux
est en forme et s'il revient ce soir
bien sûr le film est ici
on va parler du black c'est bien sûr
black soil jambes et ciara qui a tenté
de s'expliquer sur son tweet sur les
agresseurs de bernard tapie
pourquoi j'ai dit ça effectivement dans
plein d'affaires les origines ethniques
et la couleur de peau est au centre d
indignation quand c'était michel est
clair tout le monde a à souligner sa
couleur de peau on s'était dit à des
bougnats même ce qu'on s'était george
clooney c'est quelque chose dans des
délires alors sesia des bouna voilà
alors cyril je connais syrie je te
connais bien frais le père de cyril est
médecin et cyril a toujours voulu faire
carrière dans le médical il rêve d'être
cicatrisées sans que tous les cinq soit
des housses jusqu'où on va aller parce
que moi que ça leur fait acheter à
pigalle j'ai vu un tunisien tout nu à
chanter la marseillaise ce qu'on va le
recevoir demain je me demande surtout
j'ai comptabiliser le temps de parole
des invités regarder le classement à la
voilà donc jean messier à 7800 minutes
un jean chalencon 6100 minutes et 2000
et sylvia 3500 pilule ce qui est fou
c'est que le mec revient tout le temps
alors que la plupart du temps quand le
reçoit il s'est humilié je vous dis la
vérité
yassine belattar sur twitter justement
publiquement dit que j'ai une tête de
chameaux que j'ai une fête bobbio lénine
entre les femmes là entre la haine
contre les homosexuels
la détestation
juste avant je lui avais dit qu'il était
un rap plateau nous sommes comme moi
eelv avril alors moi j'ai peur que j'en
mets cia ils viennent juste quand jouer
ça finisse comme ça
[Applaudissements]
alors là tant que j'ai d'ailleurs en
train de se dire ou es ce que je peux
mettre un canot l'émission de ce film me
rappelle l'arche de noé du recueil les
cas les plus désespérés moi-même tu m'as
trouvé sur le bon coin entre un appareil
à raclette et une étagère et tu pourras
pas sauvé tout le monde ça c'est clair
on les mercredis le jour des enfants
voici un petit cours d'histoire
savez-vous les chroniqueurs qui a mis
fin à la première république géraldine
c'est toi la plus diplômée je sais pas
bah voilà
napoléon 1er en 2006 a mis fin la
deuxième république il ya des gens qui
l'ont vécu ici ouais c'est après après
louis philippe et napoléon iii
j'aimerais souligner président merci oui
après le voisin me république troisième
république au labo
metin mettant une quatrième république
de gollum et qui va mettre fin à la
cinquième république frère c'est qu'ils
vierge en chalencon les élites qu'on
mérite
si on avait su que le pire ennemi de la
république c'est un plateau de crevettes
frère alors y avait pierre jean chalon
sont le batman de la coquille
saint-jacques essayé de se justifier sur
ses dîners clandestins 1
il y en a des pmp semaine pierre jean
chalencon nous expliquer alors qu'il
organisait effectivement des rencontres
mai à 17h30 et en nombre limité je
cherche mais à 17 ans sauf que voilà ce
matin le collectionneur était en direct
sur bfm télé et a totalement fait
machine arrière
il a alors expliqué que tout ça était en
fait un poisson d'avril c'était un
énorme poisson d'avril
un poisson d'avril qui a marché voilà il
a dit c'est un poisson d'avril
on est le sat avril frère alors moi j'ai
un portable qui à fresnes en ce moment
la prison et ils essaient de se
justifier devant la dure dix ans madame
le braquage c'est un poisson d'avril
voilà la belle a pris 50 jours voilà en
tout cas cyril je sais pas ce qui va se
passer ce soir mais je serai devant ma
télé bones envers ses moyens
[Applaudissements]